you know when you're focused on food the
first criteria always has to be is it
delicious you know unless you have a
very specific concept you're working on
where you know deliciousness isn't
paramount but that almost never comes up
food should be delicious and so this is
kind of the first goal you're working on
but when I approach a food problem I
approach it almost in exactly the same
way that I you know would have
approached an art and art problem and
that is take you know first of all start
with something a premise I mean the
hardest thing to do with anything is to
start whether it's you know figuring out
what I was gonna build when I was doing
sculpture performance or you know what
am I going to put on a plate well you
know once you start right then the idea
is to always be critical about the
decisions you're making always be a
hundred percent critical all of the time
and if you can do that and if you have
the focus to be able to you know
constantly strive to make yourself
better remember the mistakes you've made
in the past then you can start working
towards making a better product or
making something that satisfies you more
I think you know what's interesting
about cooking versus making sculpture is
that to me it satisfies a lot of the
same a lot of the same energies the
energies the idea is to make something
new to make something better to
constantly be working I think you know
that's that's kind of the commonality is
is to constantly strive to learn to
change and and to work constantly and if
you if you have that when you were doing
art then you're good because you're
constantly working and changing
hopefully getting better or making new
things that make you make you
continually satisfied on a continuous
basis and the same thing happens when
you cook at least if you cook the way
that I cook which is to always
investigate new avenues new channels for
you know for for the dining experience
so that's kind of what motivates me for
me it's an it wasn't much of a change to
go from sculpture to food
although it can seem kind of like a big
change from the outside
you